[Musique]
le paysage de savane
c'est le centre géographique du brésil
c'est l'emplacement qui a été choisie
par un groupe d'économistes de
politiciens et d'urbanistes pour la
construction d'une ville entièrement
artificiel créé uniquement par la
volonté des hommes pour être la capitale
de l'an 2000 brasilia la seule ville au
monde construite en fonction de l'avenir
il ya de célébrer son premier
anniversaire dominées par le gratte-ciel
du parlement se reflète dans les eaux
d'un bassin artificiel
cette ville du futur et de l'espoir
n'est encore qu'un immense champ
cette statue qui semblent danser le
palais de l'émerveillement et de la
surprise au centre de la place des trois
pouvoirs rappelle que l'emplacement de
brasilia était autrefois le domaine
misérable des indiens
[Musique]
sur les bords du lac artificiel que le
président kubitschek père spirituel de
brasilia a fait construire sa résidence
habitée aujourd'hui par son successeur
le président croissance
cette maison blanche se prolonge par une
petite chapelle aux formes surprenantes
ces buildings de verre qui s'alignent le
long de l'avenue centrale font penser
aux constructions de park avenue à new
york
ce sont les ministères en quittant leur
bureau de rioz les fonctionnaires
brésiliens sont devenus des pionniers ce
style moderne ne peut choquer personne
tout est remarquablement d'équilibré
dans cette ville où on peut concevoir et
construire dans l'espace suivant le voeu
exprimé par le président ould cheikh qui
voulait être brasilia soit une ville
libre de tout contrat
[Musique]
en forme de couronne d'épinés voici la
cathédrale une ossature de ciment des
piliers seront reliés entre eux par les
vicomtes
ce n'est pas la base d'une pyramide mais
le terrain n'est pas achevé les feux de
la rampe sont déjà allumé ce sera sans
doute le plus moderne du monde
brasilia qui sera une ville s'en feront
toutes les artères importantes sont
doubles des croisements sont
soigneusement tv
ces routes qui ne seront jamais submergé
par le flot des voitures
à certains endroits la circulation se
fait à trois niveaux dit et cette ville
a été dessiné par un urbaniste monsieur
lucien costes bâtiments officiels ont
été construits par un architecte célèbre
dans le monde entier
oscar ni maï dans sa propriété de rio
nous avons rencontré celui qui devant
l'histoire sera le seul responsable de
la réussite de l'échec artistique de
cette ville oui j'aimais aucune excuse
si les choses n'ont pas bons on dit en
france que vous avez beaucoup subi les
influences de le corbusier je pense que
le corvaisier malgré ça la son âge là la
preuve j'en achetais il est le travail
comme le volant avec toute liberté et
sans aucune provocation avec les choses
fonctionnaliste il va faire plus
parlement les choses jolies différents
vous avez l'intention de faire de
brasilia la ville la plus moderne du
monde
non je suis ma tête je vais fermer
ville c'est possible des jolies si
possible fonctionnel et principalement
si possible pour les hommes qui nous
sommes une société différents papes une
société capitaliste de ces socialistes
avaient tous les hommes enlèvent tout
les mêmes possibilités
il est même système d'éviter tout le
touriste brasilia c'est avant tout la
capitale officielle celle on peut
entendre jouer la garde républicaine ont
les uniformes voulu historique constitue
un charmant anachronisme dans cette
ville du xxième siècle
comme toutes les villes du monde
brasilia a un maire un peu effrayé par
le rythme de croissance de sa vie vient
illuminer était de quatre fonds
inhabitat actuellement nous avons 150
donc brasilia n'est pas en danger
non je ne je ne pense pas qu est ce qui
est possible pour un étranger de venir
s'installer à brasilia oui nous voulons
d'art tunnels et angers vient ici nous
aider dans la construction à la pâte à
brasilia recèle cette visite vie pour
tout le monde non seulement les brésil
le brésil
brasilia sera vraiment la capitale
officielle lorsque les ambassades
ils seront installés au centre d'une
zone est qui dans quelques années sera
un élégant quartier diplomatique
nous avons découvert l'ambassade de
france
pour l'instant le protocole n'a pas
encore imposé sa rigueur et diplomates
sont des pionniers à leur manière et
notre ambassade de france nous reçoit
monsieur buy ins a toutes les apparences
d'un postale c'est pas un poste à
essence est plutôt un poste avancé que
nous avons ici et ce poste est confié à
de mes collaborateurs georges mckenna
ans qui est installée ici avec sa
famille depuis une quinzaine de jours et
vous fait la navette à je fais la
navette régulièrement je l' ai déjà fait
c'est mon quatrième voyage et je pense
venir au moins deux fois par mois ici
notre pas triste de quitter rios
difficile à dire mais enfin brasilia des
avantages c'est d'abord la capitale du
travail et vous y croyez à brésilien âgé
croyait fermement à brasilia évidemment
quand on voit tous ces bâtiments surgi
en un an
on ne peut que croire à brasilia petit à
petit cette ville de pierre et de ciment
s'éveille à la vie elle perd sa froideur
pour acquérir tout doucement sa
personnalité elle s'humanise brasilia
ville éprouvette s'efforce de prendre a
réagi un cinéma
une église dédiée à fatima et bien sûr
des caps
dans la longue et unique rue commerçante
de la ville nous avons fait des
découvertes surprenantes
telle cette banque française ce
restaurant tenu par un ancien jockey de
chantilly ce taxi simca appartient à un
jeune français qui me conduit chez son
père monsieur noël qui tient une
épicerie bio je pense que je suis un des
plus anciens français de la colonie de
principe
comment vous êtes arrivé ici comment
était la ville la ville n'y avait
absolument rien du tout ce seulement
l'hôtel le palace hôtel était en
construction
c'était le far west mais c'était tout
est complet oui baraques en bois
regretté l'économie sinon très satisfait
d'être venu ici
et vous croyez à brasilia à l'avenir de
pages de cours à vous êtes sûr que ça
arrive et je suis sûr ça va marcher
formidablement ça marchera terriblement
cette femme qui est au bar mais je vous
parle
bonjour madame
alors votre mari m'a dit vous êtes
satisfait d'être aussi bon pour moi
personnellement je préférais très
sérieux mais j'avais une vie beaucoup
plus agréable et pourquoi vous êtes
venus semble poursuivre mon mari je
continue la loi française c'est bien
marié en france
je saurai génère de deux tours de nantes
où il n'est jamais retourné avant si
déjà deux fois et je prétends partir
maintenant mois de juin nous on vient de
réussir assure êtes devenu brésilienne
oui je suis d'ailleurs en train de
traiter une naturalisation brésilienne
100 mètres plus loin un photographe rené
soudan il habite juste en face de son
magasin dans l'une de ses maisons qui
construisent tout sur le même modèle
ressemble à des alvéoles mais dont
l'intérieur est assez confortable
qu'est ce que vous faisiez en france
beaucoup de choses le véritable métier
je terminais j'étais fonctionner ce que
vous avez l'impression d'être un
pionnier ici d'être en aventurier ou
même pas j'ai un besoin juste un garçon
qui accomplissent pays qui ont compris
qu'il fallait venir les recentrer pas
traîner au milieu du parcours en bord de
mer d'une vie facile à ryung
vous aimez la difficulté non je parle de
difficultés j'aime les choses qui sont
la plus prenante me rase il est par
exemple vous ne trouvez pas que cette
ville manque d'armes
pour l'instant oui tout un peu égaré un
peu même chose ça
mais une maquette magnifique mais je
pensais changera pas ce qu'il y ait
aussi ils ont prévu n'est ce pas ce
secteur une déviation à ses pairs
pittoresque ne sais pas encore pièce
pour la fin vous êtes d'accord avec
votre mari sa victime
j'habite et si une française à dos et la
vie à brasilia ne pose pas de problème
pour l'éducation des gens maintenant il
ya toutes les écoles même failli manquer
faculté mais je pense que l'année
prochaine dans deux ans vous pensez vous
voyez installé pour votre vie devant lui
qu'est ce que pensent vos parents
achètent passionnés qui viennent les
attendait pour vous inquiétez vous avez
donc une confiance totale nombreuses
vies dont tout le monde a donc confiance
dans l'avenir de brazil
personne ne doute de l'avenir de cette
capitale en brionnais
pourtant la vue de ces chantiers
abandonnés et a su vaincre il ya un an
ont travaillé 24 heures sur 24
aujourd'hui le président kubitschek a
cédé sa place au président pas dans ce
par souci d'économie les crédits ont été
diminués le principe même de la
construction de brasilia n'est pas
remise en cause mais le rythme de
construction n'est plus le même et on
est pris de vertige quand on voit ce
qu'il reste à faire sur ce tir est au
piano êtes combien d'ingénieurs et
environ une centaine tous brésiliens
nous sommes à peu près tous brésiliens
mais quelques uns ont été diplômés à
l'étranger comme par exemple moi j'ai
été diplômé à grenoble je suis ami et
j'ai n'ai pas l'impression que le choix
de l'emplacement a été mauvais à cause
du terrain pour construire une ville non
parce que porte une ville on n'a pas
besoin du bon terrain intérêt quelconque
mais cela cela a été étudié et c'est le
meilleur terrain qu'on attendrait dans
l'âme
avira et parce qu'on a l'impression que
ce sol quand même ce sol de brasilia est
très friable enfin que ce n'est pas un
seul qui est propice à la construction
bon le soleil était étudiée et nous
construisons sur dieu dieu qui sont
parfois assez long d'autres d'assez
grande phase est petit mais dans
l'ensemble nous n'avons pas eu des
déboires avec ça est ce que la
construction brasilia se poursuit
conformément au plan dans l'ensemble
dans l'ensemble général louis client
léger retard changement de gouvernement
changement de plan et dans l'ensemble on
peut dire que les les pages husson sont
observés est-ce que vous avez des
problèmes avec la main d'oeuvre non nous
en avons nous avons pas mal à mandeure
en abondance des gens qui n'étaient pas
spécialisés des objets qui sont venus
s'y met son qui ont réussi à s'adapter
rapidement
ils ont fait ce brésilien ils viennent
d'où ils viennent de tout le brésil mais
surtout du nord du brésil bailly
pernambouc récifs maragnon d'autres la
zone nord du brésil
ça c'est l'ouvrier alors les techniciens
vient du sud à sao paulo bailly s on
parle minas gerais héritage année
finalement cette ville a été construit
par des amateurs par des gens qui
n'étaient pas de métier au point de vue
ouvriers aux poudres on peut dire oui on
peut dire que les ouvriers sont venus
s'y s'il ne connaissait pas grand chose
à la construction
tous les soirs ces ouvriers rentrent
chez eux
camille sée parenthèse de la
construction qui construisent brasilia
n'habitent pas vrai
[Musique]
en les suivant nous avons découvert une
ville extraordinaire la ville libre on
se croirait au far west à l'époque de la
ruée vers l'or c'est l'antithèse de
brasilia
on passe du 21e siècle au 19e siècle
[Musique]
cette ville libre c'est devenue le
problème numéro un ces planches sont
amenés à disparaître être broyés par les
bulles dose la population de la ville
libre doit progressivement être
transportés dans la ville pilote c'est à
dire à brasilia la population est
réticent car ici et là sa vie ses
habitudes elle s'est installée pour
convaincre la population le gouvernement
utilise tous les moyens de persuasion
c'est ainsi que ce troubadour que vous
entendez chanter est un fonctionnaire
rémunérées par la mairie
sa fonction consiste à vanter sur sa
guitare des mérites de basile
[Musique]
il
c'est des habitants de la ville libre
hésitent à déménager il ya des raisons
plus sérieuse que les raisons châtiment
brasilia ville moderne est trop cher
pour ceux là même qui l'a construit là
combien de temps vous êtes installés ici
monsieur s'il met trois offres
vous allez rester non je compte
m'installer au profit d'autres sites à
brasilia même parce que ceci est
provisoire vous avez trouvé là-bas j'ai
trouvé mais le loyer très cher combien
payez-vous pour un nul et c'est à dire
les loyers varient entre 90000 bruxelles
et cent mille six cent mille fois le 100
m en france il n'y a pas de contrôle du
prix des loyers avoir ignoré les libre
au brésil entre le loyer libre
les brésiliens ont fait un gigantesque
paris ils ont conçu leur capital porté
par l'enthousiasmé de l'avenir c'est un
acte de foi
certains diront que brasilia c'est la
charrue avant les boeufs et six au
brésil dans ce pays qui ne vit que pour
le futur il faut bousculer les
conventions brasilia est peut-être un
défi mais un défi qui force l'admiration
et attire le respect
[Musique]